everybody's looking for inspiration
[ __ ] you got it plan to be inspired I
come to the Garden of Good and Evil
think about my life I smoked a ball and
I go [ __ ] it
things happen I gotta change things
tomorrow's another [ __ ] day you can't
cry over spilt milk you got to get up
and go you know what yesterday was
yesterday this [ __ ] boss [ __ ] and
[ __ ] that dude I'm running my own game
that's what it's all about [ __ ] it's
[ __ ] Thursday you settled then
Hillary lost what are you gonna do you
gonna sit there what the [ __ ] grab your
balls get that flag and go on my own
type of [ __ ] American but listen Joey
what did the chitterchat have five
minutes we have a spark this [ __ ]
number done coming at different
strengths this [ __ ] Skywalker
this [ __ ] thing here this is instant
inspiration you start singing opera he's
go speaking [ __ ] French that's what
I'm talkin by understanding the
inspiration tonight it's a beautiful day
to be alive you know that you might be a
little down ain't that time to be down
did you know that today is [ __ ]
economy you ain't got time to be down
you want to be down get a [ __ ] cat
problem I got time for that [ __ ]
I love my animals but when it comes time
to attack
you got to attack [ __ ] right from the
jump and this is the attack juice right
here this juice right here when I smoke
this the attack [ __ ] zone comes in I
got a beautiful date today I'm packed up
but I got meetings I poke the [ __ ]
Gentiles they gotta lie to me who gives
a [ __ ] I'm involved understand
[Music]
I'm already getting 1000 [ __ ] ideas
but anyway that's the way this it's up
deal get the [ __ ] answer you got the
answer
put your head down and tackle that
[ __ ] and go in there and don't
look back
who gives a [ __ ] what you did you lost
you [ __ ] man you didn't get the job
gets a [ __ ]
today's another day you got a roast beef
sandwich you scrap off the dust and
you're going there [ __ ] head first
that's it
well there's somebody gets there for you
sighs [ __ ] [ __ ] when you're in that
casket you ain't got to think about it
it's about you today to buy you
[ __ ] don't listen to these
[ __ ] Gentiles control get the [ __ ]
out of my face with this the Skywalk
goes on down to zero I smoked this this
morning at 7 o'clock I didn't know where
the [ __ ] I wanna smoke a bowl of some
you don't know where you are yeah but
what the [ __ ] happened I feel like some
half a moment
understand me and that's it and that's
that I'm taking a flight tonight to
Houston [ __ ] Texas all right
where it all started you [ __ ]
that don't know now you know you know
why they send this the [ __ ] 600-pound
man to Houston because it's the best
food in the [ __ ] country I'm tearing
that [ __ ] up I'm going to Chuy's I'm
gonna go to [ __ ] in some Mexican jail
with my buddy it's over I love Houston
Texas come and get it come and take it
Tommy festival back down $35 you ever
see Todd Barry uncle Joey and another
extra mile jump up and down do whatever
the [ __ ] you want to this was a hard
thing
[Music]
and that's it that's that I'm just
getting prepared I'm gonna roll around
like I take a quick shower the doctor
talked to some people get lied to go get
butt back crack and that's it that's my
[ __ ] day then I gotta fly out of here
should we do another ball it's drama
diploma which makes it let's do some
[ __ ] hardcore just [ __ ] here
this is what they gave killer Hillary
when she found out about the resume how
they had was some hardcore nigh [ __ ]
went home she said it's all over I gotta
go home have a long talk with myself
that's it [ __ ] next week it's here
that's it holidays a-and what the [ __ ]
have you done you don't have a cool what
you did this year near do what don't
feel bad
that's it Thanksgiving to you and next
Wednesday night man haven't brought em
Oh fine improv it's a very Gentile and
probably take it over the night before
Thanksgiving we went on it with clubs
and bats and [ __ ] people yelling and
good reef it will have stars next week
it's over it's over the holidays it's
over that's it
you had your chance you had your [ __ ]
ten and a half months to [ __ ] rip it
up now it's over now people are [ __ ]
their mind is somewhere else yeah I'm
thinking of Toys R Us get the [ __ ] out
of here there's [ __ ] 20s on the floor
but that's it one things happens if you
ain't happy and lt you ain't no that's
just month on you got all the [ __ ]
all the money you could hang out with
Trump you [ __ ] have a paper bag of
pure [ __ ] ain't gonna work out face
you gotta stay healthy I drink water and
that's it and that's that I'm with you
when you're with me and it want to be
what else you know why cuz we're bad
[ __ ] we move in silence nobody
even knows but comes you know people
around me and jelly smelling-bottle need
nobody around solo we show up like a
[ __ ] a lone wolf they don't even see
us but we move in silence anyway you get
ahead of myself you know smoke another
point that's all but this [ __ ]
temperature let's kill this [ __ ] I
walk already I got [ __ ] the door people
to see I'll let you on your [ __ ] way
all right
it's a beautiful day man take advantage
of it the sun's shining the birds are
chirping and you're sitting in the press
about what what are you depressed about
some [ __ ] [ __ ] that don't matter
every time you get the precedent about a
situation I want you to think about you
lying on a casket
is it gonna [ __ ] matter [ __ ] them
redirect your energy and go around the
other way
[ __ ] them all go through that's what I
do I go through did it suck my dick and
call me shorty I was born in 1940
I got felonies I'm ugly in fact I'm
CUBAN guess what I don't give a [ __ ] I
show up with two guns on [ __ ]
tourists and I advise you to do the same
[ __ ] smoke some bliss [ __ ] first
and then go out there look at things a
little different everything's green
beans WK & z alright gotta take two
steps to the rape and get out of here I
love you [ __ ] see you tomorrow
night
Houston the podcast in town for the
weekend very funny Greg Fitzsimmons
informative [ __ ] but my girl last
night Vicky passed I love her to death
go do your thing don't come back do you
have a [ __ ] lunchbox and right I have
a great day uncle Joey loves you your
family loves you and that's all that
[ __ ] matters at the end oh we ain't
got a [ __ ] just got a family of 50 so I
love you you're ahead of the [ __ ]
game
now stop your [ __ ] sobbing [ __ ] tie
your [ __ ] shirt shine your shoes and
go out there let him know what a [ __ ]
they're dealing with stay black
[ __ ] uncle Joey